Our thirst for exploration
has transformed our species
from nomads into astronauts,
spurring new innovations,
opening up the globe,
and clearing the path
to new and distant worlds.
We explore, not just
to reach new lands
but for the journey itself.
It is in the adventure that
we discover who we really are.
Our discoveries
about the world are
rivaled only by what
has been revealed
about the human condition.
We are a race of explorers.
We risk our lives in the
pursuit of new frontiers, new
experiences, and new knowledge.
The spirit of discovery
is built into our biology,
our culture, and our mythology.
No man can fully grasp how
far and how fast we have come.
[music playing]
Wherever adventure takes us in
the future, whatever challenges
we face, we know that
the spirit of discovery
will always guide us.
Our journey has only just begun.
We set sail on this
new sea because there
is new knowledge to be gained.
Because that goal will serve to
organize and measure the best
of our energies and skills.
Because that challenge is one
that we're willing to accept.
The vast stretches of the
unknown and the unanswered
still far outstretch our
collective comprehension.